welcome back i'm here with the queens of
clean who have organized spaces for some
of our favorite stars like reese
witherspoon reddick chris pratt neil
patrick harris and here to debut the
season two trailer of their hit series
the home edit and spoiler alert
i get to be on it this season i'm so
excited please welcome back to our show
our dear friends claire shearer and
joanna teplin thanks for having
so us to be with you guys
i get to do the show we get to do this
show together
now um would you guys like to do um the
honors of taking us into you know
cleared okay
here's an exclusive first look at the
home edit season 2 trailer
was the um oh hi
i'm clea and i'm joanna we are
professional organizers post get
organized on netflix everything changed
overnight we have clients all over the
country
including some celebrities
how do you do it
oh wow they have this way about them
that adds a magic to the entire space
this space has just been overwhelming
okay into the chaos i literally have
like a million props i mean that's why
you guys are here challenge accepted
clean up everybody everywhere no you
missed that line
i went through the process of this show
because this stuff was overtaking my
house right and my family's space is
getting smaller and smaller we would
love nothing more than to give you back
your home okay don't fall nope the
pressure is extremely on we've never
been fully taken down by a project but
there's always a first for everything
too okay
you're drinking soy sauce and you're
eating salt you made a bigger failure by
drinking wine and champagne
seriously
[Music]
there it is this calms my anxiety in a
way that i can't quite explain
i'm not kidding
[Applause]
i
can't believe i get to button that
trailer i get so emotional watching that
you know what is one of the highlights
of this season for you one of the most
fun things is we got to work with almost
every single person on our team was on
the show so we were able to collaborate
with so many incredible organizers who
work for us trust me joanna and i are
the b team at this point totally um and
it was just so fun and working on
projects like yours which was just
incredible it's so many spaces outside
of the home yeah so many incredible
clients i mean last season too but the
season
just it was incredible to meet people
all over the country that are struggling
with needing organizational help and i
have to say so rewarding
it's fun but it's gonna make your life
better it really does and you guys are
just the greatest okay clea and joanna
season two of the home edit premieres
april 1st on netflix i'll be binging it
or savoring it and everything in between
thank you guys so much
[Music]
you